The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today
I want to finish up
a couple of loose
ends in the class.
The first is by
the end of the day,
we'll talk about EPR
that we've picked up
on the last couple of lectures.
We're going to close
up Bell's theorem
from the very beginning.
So we talked about
Bell's Inequality,
and we'll re-prove
and then we'll see what quantum
mechanics has to say about it.
But first, I want to
show you something neat.
So a couple of times, we've
talked about entanglement,
and what it can do.
And I want to spend the first
good chunk of the class talking
about what entanglement can
do, and also what it can't.
So before we get started, I
want to remind you of a couple
things from the last lecture.
So the first is
particles can have spin.
Half-integer intrisic
angular momentum
that has nothing to
do with being a rigid
object that rotates, but is
just an intrinsic property
of angular momentum.
And this spin is
observable-- it's
represented by an operator.
In fact, a vector of
operators, Sx, Sy, and Sz,
that satisfy the same
[? computational ?] relations
as the orbital angular momentum.
Now last time, one thing we
showed is that a state which is
up-- or, for example,
down-- at an angle theta,
so if I measure the
spin along this axis,
I will always find it's
other up or down, spin-1/2,
either plus h-bar upon
2 or minus h-bar upon 2.
But I can express this
state in terms of the states
with spin, which are up
or down along the z-axis.
And we gave an
expression-- and I
challenge you to
follow the logic given
to derive this expression.
An expression for
the state, which
is, in this case, down
along the angle theta--
it went down when measuring
spin along the angle theta--
in terms of up and down of spin
along the z-axis, or long angle
0, with theta here being the
declination from the vertical.
OK.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] angle.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
There's a general
thing for this,
that says for a general angle.
And it's actually
in the notes, which
I guess weren't
posted from last time.
But it's in the notes.
And it's also easy
to derive right?
So what's the point here?
The point is you
have a spin vector,
and it's a vector, Sx, Sy, Sz.
And you can compute the
operator representing
spin along a
particular direction
by taking a unit vector
in that direction
and taking the dot product.
So that gives you a
particular linear combination
of Sx, Sy, and Sz.
But, from last time, you know
that's just some stupid matrix.
And you could express
a matrix in any basis
you want, for example,
the basis of up
and down in the z-direction,
which is what we used
last time.
Then you can find the
eigenvectors of that,
and that's how you
find these states.
So there's a very
simple generalization.
It just involves an
extra angle theta,
which is the angle
around the equator.
OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry,
phi, extra angle phi.
So we then did the
following thing.
I talked about the
Stern-Gerlach experiment
and, here in an abstract
way from the Stern Gerlach
experiment, the
core of the nugget.
And the core of it is this.
Suppose I have some spin, and
I put it in a particular state.
Let's say, for simplicity, up
in the z-direction plus down
in the z-direction
with equal amplitudes.
So they're equally
likely to be measured.
And then, these guys,
these two states,
should be degenerate in
energy, because the system is
rotationally invariant.
It's just a spin, sitting there.
There's rotational
invariance, so we
know the energy can't depend on
the z-component of the angular
momentum.
But we can break that symmetry
and break the degeneracy
by turning on a magnetic field.
So for a Stern-Gerlach
experiment,
we turn on a magnetic
field that had a gradient.
But I just want to look at
a constant magnetic field
for the moment and
see what it does.
So we turn a constant
magnetic field.
That's a contribution of
the energy, which is minus
the magnetic field dot
the magnetic moment, which
is a constant times the spin.
But if the magnetic field
is in the z-direction,
then this is just Bz Sz.
So we then found yesterday
that this led to a splitting--
that the up state had
energy plus h-bar omega,
and the down state had
energy minus h-bar omega,
where omega is given by
mu naught Bz upon two.
Yesterday, we had
an additional term
which involved the z
dependence, the beta z term,
but here I'm just looking at
a constant magnetic field.
But if we know the
energies are, these
are still the eigenstates
of the energy operator.
If we know the
energies are, we know
how the system evolves in time.
Here is the initial state.
These are the eigenstates.
The energies are these.
So we can let the system
evolve in the time,
and we find that
all we do, is we
evolve the system with phases.
This is as usual in
quantum evolution.
If you have an expansion of the
state in energy eigenstates,
time evolution is just
phases for each term.
But note that there's
a simple thing.
This omega, the
thing that determines
the rate of evolution
of the phase,
is controlled by
magnetic moment, which
is something intrinsic to spin,
and the magnetic field, which
is something I can
dial in an experiment.
I can really tune it.
Meanwhile, we decide how long
to leave the magnetic field on.
I can turn the magnetic
field on for a while,
and I could turn
it off while later.
So suppose I leave the
field on for time t,
such that omega t is
equal to pi upon 2.
OK.
So you turn on the magnetic
field for a time t,
such that omega t
is pi upon 2, or t
is equal to pi upon 2 omega.
What is the state
then, afterwards?
The state subsequently psi
after, is equal to this guy--
omega t is equal to pi upon 2.
But what's e to the i pi upon 2?
i.
Right?
And e to the minus i
pi over 2, is minus i.
So this is an i and a minus i.
I can pull out the i so that
the phi after is i, a phase,
upon root 2 times
up z, minus down z.
Yeah.
That's cool.
And this is a state
that we saw last time.
It's actually up
to normalization,
which is an i, up or down
x in the x-direction.
So what this lets us do is
something really quite cool.
What this tells us is that all
these calculations are just
the Stern-Gerlach
calculation, but even easier,
because we don't
have a gradient.
If we have the spin in
some superposition, which,
incidentally, was initially up
and down in the z-direction,
this is equal to up
in the x-direction.
So in x, we have it up.
We turn on a magnetic field
in z, and what happens
is the spin precesses
around the z-axis.
And we get down.
We get precession.
Here's the important point.
The important point
for everything
that's going to follow is this.
If I have some spin
state, and I want
to take it to some other
spin state, how do I do so?
Well, I can build a
machine that does it,
by turning on the
appropriate magnetic field
and having the magnetic
field precess the spin.
OK.
Here I found exactly
what magnetic field
I need to turn on, with what
amplitude, and for how long,
such that I think the
state up x to down x,
with a known phase i.
Everyone cool with that?
So any unit-- here's the
thing I want to convince you
of-- any unitary
operation that takes you
from from one spinner to
another spinner-- up z,
down y, linear combination
of up and down z,
some particular linear
combination of up and down x.
Any such pair of
vectors can be related
by unitary transformation.
And any such unitary
transformation
can be built by some
series of magnetic fields.
That cool?
You can just can prove this
yourself quite quickly,
but let me just state it.
So now this gives us the
ability to do the following.
One, we have spins,
one, spins that can
be put in a system
that can be put
in states like up z and down z.
And two, the ability
to rotate states.
The ability to evolve
states from state to state.
From spin state 1 to
psi 2 by turning on some
magnetic fields, so by suitably
choosing our magnetic fields.
Everyone cool with that?
So here's a question I want to
ask, what do we do with this?
Imagine we really had this
equipment in front of us.
What power, what awesomeness
could we realize?
And this is the entry
point to quantum computing.
The answer to what can you
do with this cool machinery
is you build a quantum computer.
So let's talk about
what that means.
So quick question, do
quantum computers exist?
Yeah.
Are they very big?
No, OK.
The biggest quantum computer
that's been built my knowledge
is one that has factored
the number fifteen
Or they might have
done 21 at this point,
I'm not exactly sure.
21?
Done?
Yeah, OK.
21's done.
So that's the upper end.
Well, they're large, physically.
It's true.
They take up a room.
Or at least a large table
top, an optics table.
But they're not very
big in a useful sense.
OK.
And there's actually reasonable
people, not just reasonable,
intelligent people--
and reasonable.
That's a nontrivial-- Ok.
The people who live
at the intersection
of intelligent and
reasonable, which,
admittedly as my
colleague is pointing out,
is not a large overlap.
There are people
in that overlap who
suspect that, for some
fundamental reason,
it's impossible to build
a useful quantum computer,
in some deep, deep sense.
I don't know whether
that's true or not.
But we're about to engage in a
discussion of what happens when
you build quantum
computers for n bits
were n gets large, like
millions and billions
as you need for codes
or for studying images.
And, of course, this
is a little strange,
because such a
compter doesn't exist,
which leads to my colleague
and friend Scott Aaronson's
lovely comment that his job,
as someone who studies quantum
computers, is to
prove things that
can't be done with
computers that don't exist.
Which is what we're
about to do, so.
So let's talk about
quantum computing.
So what do I mean by
quantum computing?
Here's the basic idea.
Let's talk about
classical computing.
Classical computing
says, I have these things
called bits, which
are binary objects.
They're either 0, or they're 1.
And we realize them in
a very particular way.
We realize them with
a little magnet,
which points north or south.
Now, it's not always
exactly a magnet.
It isn't like an old-style
hard disk in your computer.
It's something a little more
fancy than just a magnet.
But it's still
basically a magnet,
and you have some north, south.
And whether it's pointing
north, or whether it's
pointing south down
here, which I'll call 0.
Or whether it's pointing north
down here, which I'll call a 1,
determines whether
you call this 0 or 1.
And classical
computation is your data
are a set of numbers--
what's pointing down.
And the process of doing
a classical computation
is, build a machine
which is governed
by classical mechanics,
OK, that takes
this initial configuration
and replaces it
with a new one, f of 0, 1.
Which is also some number,
so maybe it's 0, 0.
I don't know--
it's whatever f is.
And what you want
to do is you want
to perform some calculation,
which is some function, a known
function, of your
input variables--
a function, in this case,
of two bits, which produces
the output that
you want, and you
build a machine that does that.
OK.
So let me give you an example.
I want to build a
classical computer that
takes a string of binary
integers-- 0, 0, 1, 0, 0.
And performs a logical [? NOT ?]
on each bit independently.
So I need to build that computer
out of objects available to me.
OK.
And I need to use nothing
other than the laws
of classical mechanics.
That has to suffice to
describe the system.
So let me give an example
of such a computer.
Why, Allen, why don't
you do this calculation?
OK.
So, that's the
input, and I am now
the classical computer 0, 1, 1.
Right?
Now that's not actually what
you do in your cell phone
or on your laptop.
That uses transistors, but
it's the same basic idea.
You build a set of machines.
You build a set of objects,
you know, magnetic fields,
electric currents that
effect this calculation.
And so there's some relationship
between what electric fields
you turn on and
what currents you
induce to flow and
the calculation
you want to perform--
f of the input.
OK, this is a basic idea
of a classical computer.
Oh, and one last thing.
Suppose we have n bits.
Suppose we have
n classical bits.
Then we have 0, 1, the end.
And how many numbers
do you have to specify
to specify the
configuration of n bits?
This is sort of [INAUDIBLE].
No, you just need to specify
the number of each bit, right?
So we need n bits.
So n binary numbers.
Everyone cool with that?
I specify what each
register is, and I'm done.
Imagine this is
quantum mechanical.
Instead of having bits, let's
take quantum mechanical bits.
By which I'm going
to mean a system
that has two possible
observable states, 0 and 1.
OK.
So these are the possible
observable states.
And to specify a
general configuration,
I see that psi is equal to
some linear combination, alpha
0 plus beta 1.
Now, if I measure, we know
that we'll find either 0 or 1.
If we measure the spin
in the z-direction,
we will measure
either up or down.
However, at a given
moment in time,
the system need not be
in a state corresponding
to a definite value.
It could be in a
general superposition.
Agreed?
So now here's the question.
How do you how many
numbers does it
take to specify the state
of a single quantum bit?
Two complex numbers.
Right?
It takes two complex numbers
to specify the state of a bit.
And if we have n qubits, and
there are n of these guys,
well then, how many
numbers does it take?
Well, I have to
specify the state
of every possible
superposition for
every possible
configuration the system.
So, for example, it could be
all 0, 0, 0, dot dot dot 0,
plus beta.
The first one is 1, and the
rest are 0, dot dot dot plus.
And how it terms are there?
There are 2 to the n terms.
Right.
So how many numbers do I need to
specify this state of n qubits?
I need 2 to the n
complex numbers.
Yeah?
Everyone see that?
So this immediately leads to
a really frustrating reality
we have to face.
Suppose you want to simulate,
using a classical computer,
such as sits on my desktop, I
wanted to simulate a quantum
mechanical system of n
bits, or n spin-1/2 states,
evolving according to
some energy function--
evolving according to some
Hamiltonian [INAUDIBLE].
How many variables, and how
much memory will it take?
2 to the n, right?
If I've got n bits that
I want to describe,
it's going to take 2 to
the n complex numbers.
So that's how many
variables I have.
So if I have 10 bits, literally,
10 little spin-1/2 objects,
to accurately specify the
quantum configuration system,
I need 2 to the 10
complex numbers.
And that's for 10 spins.
How many things make
this piece of chalk?
Right?
So could you ever,
in an honest way,
simulate on a
classical computer,
like sits on my desktop, a
quantum mechanical system
the size of this chalk.
Absolutely not.
It's completely and
utterly intractable.
You have to come up with some
sort of approximation scheme.
So simulating quantum
systems directly,
by just taking the spins and
representing them with a wave
function, is wildly inefficient.
Incredibly difficult.
Interestingly, the converse
is almost certainly not
so difficult.
It's almost certainly
possible for a quantum system
to simulate classical
evolution quite easily.
And how do you know that?
Yeah, here we are.
Exactly, right?
Nature apparently has no trouble
simulating classical mechanics
with underlying
quantum mechanics.
Quantum mechanics is
the operating system,
and classical mechanics is
the simulation it's running.
Yeah, in a very useful
sense, a very real sense.
So, at this point,
Feynman, I think,
was the first person who
really pointed this out.
I don't know the
details of the history,
but the lore is that this was
really from his observation.
Look, if that's
true, this opens up
a real possibility
for computation.
If things like spins-- hard
problems like calculating
how spins evolve or even the
motion of chalk in the room--
can be done pretty efficiently
by nature, a comput
if we can build a computer that
used quantum mechanical bits,
whose variables were
quantum mechanical,
and involved all the
superpositions and interference
effects of quantum
mechanics, perhaps we
could build computers
that run exponentially
faster and with
exponentially less memory
and less resources than
classical computer would.
Because apparently
it works, right?
We're here, as was
previously said.
So this is the question
of quantum computing.
Can you use quantum mechanics?
Can use, in particular, the
quantum evolution of the system
to perform calculations
that you care about,
rather than classical
computation?
And if you do so, do
you gain anything?
Do you get any
sort of speed ups?
Is there an enhancement?
Is anything better?
So, here's the basic gig.
The basic gig is that we're
going to take our system,
considering the following
kinds of systems.
Our systems are going to
be n qubits or n spins.
But because I want to
emphasize that the substrate
doesn't matter--- the underlying
material doesn't matter--
I'm going to refer
to them purely,
and this is totally typical
in the field, as qubits,
rather than spin systems.
And the reason is it might
work use little isolated
spinning particles
with intrinsic spin.
Or that might turn out to be
technologically infeasible.
It shouldn't matter at the end
of the day, in the same way
that if I ask you, how
does you computer work?
Or if I ask you to
write a code, you
write some code in C
or Python or whatever--
what the hip kids
are using these days.
So you write some little Scheme
code-- I still love Scheme.
You write some
little Scheme code,
and it performs some
calculation as to defined
in just logic, in lambda
calculus, in abstract logic.
Do you need to
know the substrate?
So you need to know whether
your transistors are built out
of silicon or germanium?
Or indeed, whether it's
running on vacuum tubes?
No, that's the whole point of
abstracting away computation.
The substrate doesn't matter.
So we can use spin-1/2.
And that's going to be useful
for us at various moments.
But I want to emphasize
the important thing
is the actual logic
of the process,
not the underlying substrate.
Here's what I need.
My systems are going
to be n copies,
or n qubits, where each bit
is specified by either 1,
represented by up, or
0, represented by down.
I'll use these interchangeably.
So that the full system, psi,
is a superposition of sum
over all possible-- sorry,
I didn't mean to write that.
So this is my system.
It's going to evolve according
to some energy operation.
And so my input is going to
be some wave function, psi n,
for these n qubits.
Computation is going to
be, evolve with some energy
operator-- which I've chosen--
to implement an algorithm,
in the same way that the precise
series of magnetic fields
that we turn on in a
classical computer,
or currents that we allow to
flow in a classical computer,
implement the algorithm
that we want to effect.
We evolve with some
energy operator,
implementing our
linear algorithm,
and we get some
output wave function,
psi-- again-- for our n
bits, n quantum bits, out.
So this is the basic gig
with the quantum computation.
We're just replacing strings of
binary numbers and functions--
evolution according to
classical mechanics in Maxwell--
to other strings of numbers
with superpositions of states.
Superpositions of
strings, as it were,
evolving according to
the Schrodinger equation
into again general
superposition.
So how does this differ?
What are the key differences
from a classical computer?
So the key things are first
off, the input and output
are not definite values.
They could, in general,
be superpositions.
They do not have to correspond
to a definite state in the 1, 0
basis.
These, in general, are
superpositions of 0, 0, 0, 1,
0, 0, dot dot dot.
So the input and output
are superpositions
of the values we'll measure.
OK.
Second, when we do measure, at
the end of the day, the output,
we get interference from
the various different terms
in the superposition.
The different terms
in the superposition
will lead to
interference effects.
And so our output will be
sensitive to that interference
between the different
terms in the superposition.
It may be that we're
in some pure state.
But it may be, more
generally, we'll
be in some superposition of
the states we want to measure.
So we're going to
get interference.
So naively, this is a
disaster because this
means we get
probabilistic outcomes.
That sounds bad.
And so, this leads to the key
move in quantum computation.
Given that we're going
to have interference,
and given that those
interference effects are going
to affect the probabilities of
various outcomes, what we're
going to want is to
tune, or orchestrate,
the interference to
get a definite outcome.
We want to get the correct
answer out, rather than
just probably the
correct answer out.
Now there's a slight
variation of this.
It's not obvious at the
beginning, how to do that.
It's not even
clear that you can.
So I'm going to show
you that you can.
I'm going to show you an
explicit algorithm that
realizes this.
But, OK, that's obviously
going to be tricky.
Here's something
else you can do.
You can also focus
on special problems.
Focus on checkable problems.
And what I mean
by this is imagine
we have some algorithm
that gives us an output,
and that output is
probably the right answer.
But we're not sure.
There's some quantum
mechanical probability
that this is the correct
answer to our computation--
there's some probability
that it's not.
So, if the calculation
was difficult,
but it's easy to check whether
you have the right answer
then that's great.
Imagine it's 10% that
you get the right answer,
but it's trivial to check.
So, for example,
factoring numbers, right?
If you multiply the
numbers, that's easy.
You check to see whether
you got the right thing.
So, for example, if you imagine
that I build a computer that
is supposed to factor
numbers-- I almost
said factor prime numbers.
That would be a boring computer.
So imagine that we build a
machine that factors numbers.
Right?
And so imagine its
output is probabilistic.
So, you say 15, and
I say 3 times 5.
You say 15, I say 5 times 3.
You say 15, I say 7 tiimes 2.
At that point, you're like,
well, which one is right?
Well, you can check
by multiplying.
So if you have a problem,
which is easy to check,
but hard to do, then
probablistic is already OK.
That's just as true classically
as it is quantum mechanically.
Those are our basic moves.
And so, the key thing
for us is that when
we have n quantum bits, we have
these interference effects.
And in particular, as we
started talking about last time,
we get entanglement effects.
What we're going to
discover is that the key
to making a good
quantum algorithm
is going to go to attune the
entanglement appropriately.
So going to have to define
that for you in just a minute.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] process.
PROFESSOR: Well, it
may or may not be.
So the check, for example, ,
imagine the process I just gave
you.
So the question
is, what do you do
if the checking process
is probabilistic?
But you can use a classical
computer to check,
if you have an easy checking
algorithm-- for example,
multiplying numbers together.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No.
Good.
And so the question
then becomes,
doesn't that defeat the point
of using a quantum computer,
if you're using a classical
computer to check?
And so here's the thing.
If I ask you to factor
a gigantic number,
what do you have to do?
Well, you have to take all
numbers up to its square root,
and you have to
multiply them together,
and that takes forever.
Right?
But if I tell you,
do these two numbers
multiply to give you
the third number?
That's easy, right?
So I use a quantum
computer for the hard part,
and the classical computer
for the forward part.
For the checking.
And that's a special class of
problems which are checkable.
These all have fancy names
in information theory.
I'm not going to
use the fancy names.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the wave function?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
I mean, suppose I
give you some output,
and let's say the output
is 0, 0 plus 1, 1.
Right?
What are you going to get,
if you measure the first bit?
Well, you're either
going to get 0 or 1,
with one probability
or another, right?
When we compute
the probabilities
in general, when we have many
terms in our superposition,
we're going to get
interference effects
from different terms
in the superposition.
And those interference terms
will tune the probability,
so they're not just the naive
probability of that one thing.
But you get these
interference terms.
Norm squared of one,
norm squared of two,
and then the real part twice
real part of the cross term.
And that twice the real
part of the cross term
didn't exist classically.
Quantum mechanically,
it's important,
and it can change the
final probability.
That's what I mean by
the interference effects.
OK, so let's make all
this much more explicit.
So far I've just
given you philosophy,
and you should be deeply
suspicious of philosophy
in a physics classroom.
So, again, to be explicit,
a quantum bit, or qubit,
is equal to a two state
system, and, again,
the substrate doesn't matter.
I could be talking
about spin-1/2 systems,
or I could be talking about
ropes on a cylinder with
winding mod 2.
I could be talking about
all sorts of things.
But it's some system with
two quantum states, 0 and 1.
I want to emphasize this is
not going to be on the final.
So this is just for
your moral well being.
So a quantum bit is
a two state system.
We have these two states,
which I'll call 0 and 1,
and a general state, the
general wave function, psi,
is equal to alpha 0 plus beta 1.
OK.
And what this means is the
probability that I measure 0
is equal to norm alpha
squared, et cetera.
OK.
Now, again many
systems can be used--
many different substrates.
This is what I'm going
to mean by a qubit.
So that's one qubit.
The much more interesting
system is two qubits.
So let's study two qubits.
So in the case of two qubits,
what's a general state?
Well a general state
is going to be,
well, the first
particle could be 0
and the second particle
could also be 0.
Or we could have
the first particle 0
and the second particle
1, with some coefficient,
plus beta, plus gamma
1, 0, plus delta 0, 1.
OK.
So this is just a
general superposition.
Now, you might worry
at this point look,
are these identical, or
these non-identical spins?
But here's the thing.
I've got a spin
here-- it's in a box--
and I've got another
spin here-- it's
in a box-- I've got
another qubit over here.
It's in a box.
So they're distinguishable
because they're
in different places
in my laboratory.
So these are
distinguishable particles.
The particle in this box
is either up or down.
OK.
So these are
distinguishable, and I
don't have to worry about
symmetrizatoin, Bosonic
or Fermionc statistics,
or any of that.
They're distinguishable.
And we need normalization,
so norm alpha
squared plus dot dot
dot is equal to 1.
And what does this mean?
What this means is that,
for example, the probability
of the first part, which
I'll call a is equal to 0,
is equal to-- well, we sum
up all the possible ways
we could do that.
We have norm alpha squared
plus norm beta squared.
Whoops-- this was 1, 1.
Thank you.
And if we're more specific, the
probability of the first qubit
is 0, and the second qubit
is 1-- is equal to 1.
I need 0, 1.
That's this guy,
norm beta squared.
OK.
What I mean by two qubits.
But this immediately
leads to a funny thing.
There are two kinds of
states that a pair of qubits
could be in, a very
special set of states,
which are called
separable states.
And these are special.
And these states correspond
to the full system
being in the state where
the first particles is
in one state, and
the second particle
is in the second state.
OK.
So, for example,
this could be eg
the state 1 over
root 2-- sorry-- 0
plus 1 for the first particle,
and the second particle
to be in the state 1
over root 2, 0, minus 1.
[INAUDIBLE] Let's just call
these general coefficients.
a plus b and times c plus d.
So what does this equal to?
Well, this is of
the form-- there's
going to be a term that's
0, 0, and that's ac.
Plus a term that's 0, 1,
and that's ad with a minus.
Minus ad.
Plus a term that's 1, 0.
That's bc.
And minus a term that's
1, 1, and that's bd.
OK.
This is clearly not
generic, because it
implies relationships amongst
the alpha, beta, delta,
gamma, apart from
just normalizability.
Everyone see that?
So it's a pretty
non-trivial thing
that you can write a thing
as, the first particle is
in one state, and the second
particles in the second state.
And here's physically
what that means.
Physically, what that
means is that, if you're
in a state like this,
and I ask you, what's
the probability that I measure
the first particle to be 0,
do I need to know anything
about the state of b?
No.
If I want to know
what probability
of the first particle is 0,
I just take norm a squared.
Because I'm going
to get plus norm
c squared plus norm d squared.
So that's fine.
So, imagine the probability
of the first particle
being up or down is
independent of any information
about the second
particle, right?
There is another thing
that's important.
Suppose I tell you,
ah ha I've measured,
and the first particle
is in the state 0.
OK.
Cool?
What is the state subsequent
to that measurement?
So if we measure
a is equal to 0,
what is the state subsequent?
Psi is equal to--
well, that's 0,
and we know we've lost this,
so this particular subsystem,
this particular qubit has
been collapsed to the state 0,
so we have 0 times c, 0, minus
d, 1 for the second particle.
Have we learned
anything about the state
of the second particle?
Have we learned
anything about the state
of the second particle?
Absolutely not.
Right?
Beforehand, what
was the probability
that the second article is 0?
Norm c squared.
And the second particle 1?
Norm d squared.
Now what's the problem?
Same.
Norm c squared, norm d squared.
So when you have a
seperable system,
measuring one qubit tells you
nothing about the other qubit.
Cool?
On the other hand, consider a
state which is not separable.
So the generic states
are not separable.
And let me give you an
example of the state which
is not seperable.
Which one do I want to pick?
Yeah, what the hell.
Psi is 1 over root
2, 0, 0, plus 1, 1.
Can this be written
as the product
of the first
particle in one state
and the second
particle in the other?
No, because they were have
to be cross terms, which
don't exist here.
Right, just compare
this to that form.
So, we have that the
coefficient of 0, 0 is ac.
So a and c must
both be non-zero,
and the coefficient
of 1, 1 is bd.
So the coefficient bd must be--
both of those must be non-zero.
So ac and bd are all non-zero.
That means these terms have
to exist in order for it
to be separable.
Yeah?
Because a and b
[? can't ?] vanish,
and b and c [? can't ?] vanish
And these orthogonal states
are independent.
So this is not a
separable state.
We call these states entangled.
And it's funny,
because [INAUDIBLE] I
think there's an e in there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
That's better.
Look, I'm not a
professor of spelling.
It's a little bit funny to
give these a special name
and call them entangled, because
the generic state is entangled.
It's sort of like
calling mice, mice,
and calling all the
other mammals non-mice.
Oh look, well, that
was bad example.
Oh look at mice right
across from [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS].
PROFESSOR: Hearkening back
to an earlier lecture.
So, in any case, we give
these a special name,
and the reason we give
them a special name
is that these seperable states
do you more or less what
you'd expect classically.
There are no
strange correlations
between the state of one
and the state of the other.
They're independent quantities.
But when you have a generic
state, something funny happens.
They're entangled.
And here's the funny
thing that happens.
Suppose given the state, what's
the probability that I measure
the first particle
be up, or to be 0?
1/2.
What's the probability that
I measure the first particle
to be 1?
1/2.
So, before doing
any measurements,
the first particle is
equally likely to be 0 or 1.
So suppose I measure the
second particle to be up.
OK.
Then the probability that I
measure the first particle is 0
is equal to 0, and
the probability
that the first particle
is 1 is equal to 1,
because I've this collapse
onto this term in the wave
pack, the wave function.
So measuring the second
qubit alters the probability
distribution for
the first qubit.
These guys aren't independent.
They are correllated,
in a way that you
studied on the problem set.
They are correlated.
They're in a correlated state.
We call this correlation
entanglement.
And here's the thing that's
most spooky about this,
and we'll come back to
this in a few minutes,
but I didn't tell you
anything about the geometry
of the set up.
But, in fact, when I was
thinking of that measurement,
I built the two little qubits
in my lab, and I took one,
and I sent it to France--
because France, you know.
And I took the other one, and
I said it to the planet Zorg.
And so off on the planet is
some poor experimentalist
huddling in the cold.
And our French experimentalist
makes a measurement,
altering the probability
distribution instantaneously
on Zorg.
That should make you
a little worried.
That sounds a little crazy.
We'll come back to why
that is or isn't crazy,
and the EPR analysis,
which puts flesh on it,
sounds crazy, in a little bit.
But for the moment,
let me just emphasize
that, while the generic
state is entangled,
the generic state is
also different than what
your classical
intuition would expect.
There are correlations
between the particles.
So this is something
that happens
with quantum mechanical
particles that
doesn't happen with
classical particles.
And that means
it's something that
can be used in a
quantum computer that
can't be used in a
classical computer.
So let's see what
using entanglement
gives us for computation.
So let's go come back to the
quantum computing problem.
And how do we
compute with qubits?
So how to compute.
OK.
So again, as usual, the way we
take our input to our output
is we build a machine
that implements
an algorithm of our
choice by arranging
the physical evolution
of the system under time.
So that means picking
an electric field.
Sorry, an energy operator--
an electric field, good lord.
So it means picking
an energy operator.
OK.
So computing is Schroedinger
evolution with our chosen,
our attuned, energy operator.
So, for example, I
want to build for you
now a couple of basic
circuit elements
that you might want to
use in a quantum computer.
So example one.
The first example is, I
want to build a NOT gate
And what NOT means is
that it takes the state 0
and gives me 1, and it takes
the state 1, and it gives me 0.
OK.
This is what NOT does.
So how do I build a NOT gate?
Well, I can realize
this in a nice way.
Doot do do.
Do I want to say it that way?
Yeah, good.
So if I realize 0
as 1, 0, and 1 as 0,
1 from last lecture and 0, 1 to
1, 0, so we need an operator.
We need time evolution to effect
multiplication by an operator.
That takes this
vector to this vector,
and this vector to this vector.
We know what that
unitary operation is.
That unitary operation,
which I'll call NOT,
must equal to 0, 1, 1, 0.
And this operation takes
this guy to this guy,
and it takes this
guy to this guy.
Yeah?
But I can write this
as-- I like this-- shoot,
there's a phase-- minus i, e
to the i pi over 2, 0, 1, 1, 0.
I mean, you can't
stop me, right?
So this expanded out, as we've
done before, expanding this out
gives me, with
the exponential, 1
plus the thing and
all the other terms.
This becomes minus i times
cosine of pi over 2 times
the identity, the
2 by 2 identity,
up plus i sine of pi
over 2 times 0, 1, 1, 0.
But what's cosine of pi upon 2?
Yeah, 0.
Come on.
Is everyone that tired?
So cosine pi over 2 is 0.
Up.
Sine of pi upon 2 is 1,
because i times minus i,
that's 1 times 0, 1, 1, 0.
Pretty solid.
But what is this?
Well this is the form
Schroedinger evolution
with a magnetic field,
and this is just
the unitary transformation
unitary transformation
for a magnetic field.
Well, OK.
We can say this.
This is the x polymatrix
from last time.
So this is like Sx,
unitary transformation
for a magnetic field in the
x-direction for some time t.
For time t times the frequency,
omega, which is given by mu B
upon 2 is equal to pi upon 2.
OK.
Just like before, but for
a slightly different one.
A slightly different
magnetic field.
So my point here
is that we can pick
a magnetic field that does this.
We turn a magnetic field
with a known amplitude
with a known amount
of time, details here
don't matter so much.
The point is we can do it.
We turn a magnetic field
in the x-direction,
and it takes 0 to 1 and 1 to 0.
Everyone cool with that?
So here is a substrate,
an actual physical system
that effects this
particular evolution.
I can build a NOT.
The crucial thing is that
I can build a NOT gate.
And I'll represent that not with
some unitary transformation U
sub NOT.
So that's a useful one, but
that's not the most useful gate
because, if you only
ever impose logical NOTs,
you just get everyone angry.
But you don't actually
get anything done.
Second example-- let that be
a lesson to you, Congress.
So, the second
example, if we turn
on the magnetic field
in the y-direction
for a particular
time t, what we find
is that 0 goes to 1
over root 2, 0 plus 1,
and 1 goes to 1 over
upon root 2 0 minus 1.
And this should be familiar.
This is the up x state, and
this is the down x state.
Just as we talked before.
So we turn on some B
field, and we get this.
So this operation has
a name because it's
going to turn out to
be very useful for us.
It's taking a system that's
definitely in the state 0,
for sure, right?
And it put us in a
superposition of 0, 1.
It's a definite
superposition, so it's not
like we don't know
what happened.
But it's a superposition,
and you've lost certainty
that you'll measure
up in the z-direction.
You've gained certainty that you
measure up in the x-direction.
But if we do all our
measurements in z,
we just taking ourselves from
definite to superposition.
Cool?
So that's useful because we
know that's something a quantum
computer can do, that a
classical computer can't do.
Something a quantum
computer can take advantage
of that classical
computer can't take
advantage of is this
process of putting things
into superpositions.
So here we've got
an operation that
puts things in superpositions.
And I'll call this Hadamard.
I don't know the history of
why that's called Hadamard,
presumably there's some guy
with a last name of Hadamard.
Anyway, the U
Hadamard does this.
And as a matrix, it's
represented as 1 over root 2,
times 1, 1, 1, minus 1.
And there's a the
last one, which
is going to be useful for me,
another one is called C C-NOT.
Controlled-NOT.
Controlled-NOT does
a really cool thing.
It takes 0, 0, and 0,
1 and 1, 0, and 1, 1.
What does is it says,
I'm going to apply a NOT
to the second qubit if, and
only if, the first qubit is 1.
So this takes me to--
0, 0 goes to-- well,
do I perform an NOT on this bit?
No, so 0, 0.
Do we perform a NOT on this bit?
No, 0, 1.
Now I do perform a NOT
on 0, so I get 1, 1.
And 1, 1-- I perform a NOT on
this bit, which gives me 1, 0.
So this is called
controlled-NOT.
It's a very useful thing.
I'm going to represent
this in the following way.
I should represent all of these.
So this NOT gate, first,
I take some initial bit,
and it's in some state.
And then I impose U-NOT, and
it gives me an out state.
Similarly, with the Hadamard,
I take an initial state n,
and I've apply U Hadamard.
And I get u out.
And for controlled-NOT,
I now have two qubits.
And I take the two qubits,
and I do a controlled-NOT,
which is represented
in this form.
Which says, do a NOT
on this guy, controlled
by this first bit.
And so this acts as U C-NOT.
OK.
And the key thing here,
is that while it's always
possible to find a physical
real representation
of some particular
unitary transformation,
at the end of the day, all we're
going need is some truth table.
At the end of the
day, all we need
is the logic that's
being effected.
And so, the details
of the substrate
can be abstracted away.
So what we do with this?
First, so what can we do?
Before we actually talk about
what we can do with it, let's
briefly talk about what
you can't do with it.
So what are things you can't do
with these sorts of operations?
What can't you do?
And to me this is among
the more surprising things.
Remember that what
we're doing here
is going to be evolving a system
for a Schroedinger evolution,
and a Schroedinger
evolution is linear,
it respects superpositions,
it's unitary,
it preserves probability,
and let's just focus on that.
It's linear,
unitary, and it lots
of other properties,
[? temporal ?] invariance,
unless you turn on a
magnetic field, which you do.
But in particular, it's
linear and unitary.
And those facts are going
to constrain, powerfully,
the kinds of operations we can
effect on a quantum system.
So, in particular, when we
look at just two qubits,
there's a beautiful,
beautiful theorem
says there's no cloning.
And here's what that means.
The no cloning theorem,
pretty high flautin'
for what it really is,
which is the following.
Suppose we have a system,
which has input xy.
And I want to build a
machine that says, look,
I've got this first qubit
it in the state x, and what
I want to do is I
want to make a copy.
I want to make another
quantum system that's
in exactly the same
state as whatever x is.
So you hand me a system where
first bit's in state tax,
and the second
qubit's in state y.
And I want to make a copy of x.
And y is just, who
cares what's in it?
So I want this to go to x, x.
OK.
For all y.
So regardless of what
data was in here,
I want to overwrite
that data, and rewrite--
or that datem--
rewrite it with x.
Can you do this?
No, right.
Why?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
It would violate linearity
and also unitarity, indeed.
So to see that quickly, it's
easiest to see the unitarity,
I think.
Well, it violates them
both, but for unitarity, you
manage to take a linear
combination of these guys,
where the two states
y are orthogonal,
and you take the norm squared.
So you've normalized it to 1.
The linear combination
of each one
goes to Sx, where
the coefficient
is the sum of those two terms.
So we have, for example,
x z, alpha x z plus beta
x y goes to alpha plus beta x x.
And that's really bad, because
if x, z, and y are orthogonal,
then normalization is alpha
squared plus beta squared is 1.
But x x, the
normalization is alpha
plus beta quantity squared is 1.
And in general that's not true.
In fact, this could be 0.
So this violates linearity
and a unitarity rather badly.
So you can't clone.
This is really disturbing.
That means if you
have a quantum,
and you want make a
copy of it, you can't.
You can't ever make a copy
of your quantum system.
One copy.
One chance.
That's it.
No cut and paste.
So, as you can imagine
that pretty powerfully
constrains things
that you can do.
So, a related thing here is
that there's no forgetting.
Quantum evolution is, unlike an
elephant, it is highly-- well,
it's like an elephant, I guess.
It remembers very well.
It never forgets anything.
And you can see that from this.
This would be an
example of forgetting.
You forgot what
was in the state y.
You can't ever do that.
OK.
So I leave this as a challenge
you to prove this show.
It's a simple extension
of the same logic.
So what can you do?
What you can do, is you
can entangle two qubits.
And that's really the
juice of everything.
You can entangle.
So let me show you entanglement.
Good, no e.
Sorry, question?
So you can entangle, and
here's how you do it.
Let's take this state 0, 0.
So we have two qubits.
The first one's in the
state 0, and the second one
is in the state 0.
And now, I'm going to do the
following set of operations
to it.
I'm first going to
impose a Hadamard
operation on the first qubit,
and nothing on the second.
And then I'm going to
apply controlled-NOT,
and we're going to
see what I get out.
So the initial state is 0, 0.
After I Hadamard, well, the
first bit is no longer in 0.
Hadamard on 0 gives me 0 plus 1.
So this is now the
state 1 upon root 2.
0 plus 1 times 0, also known as
1 over root 2, 0, 0 plus 1, 0.
Now is this the separable state?
Yes, there is separated.
And now I'm going to
perform a controlled-NOT
and what the
controlled-NOT does,
is that it switches the second
bit, if the first bit is a 1.
So what is the state
after we've done this?
The state after we've done this
is, well, from the first term,
1 upon root 2,
from the first term
0, 0-- what happens to that
when we controlled-NOT?
Well, we NOT this if this is 1.
This is not 1, so
we don't NOT it.
We leave it alone.
And the second term--
1, 0 plus well, we
flip this, if this is 1, and
not if it's not, so this is 1.
We flip it, and we get 1, 1.
And now this is the
prototypical entangled state--
that I think I just erased.
But this is our entitled state.
It's not separable.
But if I measure
the first one, I
know what the state
of the second one
is, which is to
say it's entangled.
Cool?
So by performing this
series of operations, which
is nothing other than a
series of magnetic fields
which I'm going to
impose to the system,
I've taken a state
with initial conditions
0, 0, and put it into an
entangled state, 0, 0 plus 1,
1.
And that's all we need for
the first basic algorithm
of quantum computation.
So this idea the
quantum computers
might be able to
do things faster
than classical computers
floated around for a while.
It took a while for
people to make that sharp.
And David Deutsch, who is a
very entertaining and bombastic
speaker, and he wrote-- I
guess it's several now-- pretty
entertaining books on the topic.
And he sounds crazy.
You listen to the guy
talk, and he sounds nuts.
He sounds like he's
just way out there.
The thing he's just-- gah!
As a theorist, you listen to
him like, just slow down there,
buddy.
Right?
And so for a long time,
I thought the guy--
I only knew his sort
of public persona--
I thought, yeah, he's
a little bit crazy;
I'm not exactly
sure-- and this is
why everyone thinks
he's such a damn genius.
Because this is beautiful.
So here is-- I don't know
how he came up with this,
but he's clever.
So here is what's now
called the Deutsch--
and it's really
the one bit version
of the Deutsch-Josza algorithm.
So there is a first
algorithm by Deutsch
that didn't quite what
it was supposed to do,
then it was improved
together with Jozsa,
and they made an n particle
version and everything was
awesome.
But here's the
Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm.
And what it is, it's
a series of rules
for how to make a quantum
mechanical system evolve
so as to effect the calculation
you wanted to calculate.
So you have to
grant, to begin, you
have to let me pose
a problem to solve
that can be solved
in this fashion.
And this problem is going
to sound a little contrived.
And, in fact, it's
wildly contrived.
It was contrived
so that it could
be solved in this fashion.
But it's actually one that
preexists the algorithm itself,
so it's not quite as ridiculous
So here's the problem.
So the statement
of the problem is
that someone has
a function f of x.
So, let's say Matt
knows a function f of x.
Now the thing is, it's
extremely expensive
to evaluate this
function f of x.
So the way you evaluate
involves putting 20 kilomeres
in superposition
states with each other.
You have to run a
whole experiment.
And it costs a lot of money
to run, so he charges--
$1 million dollars order to--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Thank you, you
guys are not quite old
enough to-- so he knows
the function f of x and he
charges a million dollars in
order to evaluate the function.
You say, hey, Matt, look, I
know this is a function-- which
I should tell you f
is a function that
takes a single bit, 0 or 1,
to another single bit, 0 or 1.
So it sounds like, how hard
could this possibly be?
But in fact, it's a very
hard function to evaluate.
So you say, hey
Matt, what's f of 0?
And he's like, give
me a million bucks.
So you give him a million bucks.
And he's like, 1.
And you're like damn,
that cost a lot of money.
So now here's the question.
So this is not yet the problem.
The problem is this.
Is f of 0 equal
to f of 1 or not?
OK.
So f of 0 is either 0 or
1. f of 1 is either 0 or 1.
Are they equal to each other?
So this is easy, right?
Classically, this is stupid.
You calculate the
function f twice.
You evaluate f of
0, you get a number.
You evaluate f of 1,
and you get number.
You look at your piece
of paper, and you
say it's either the
same or different.
How much does that cost you?
Two million bucks.
Better have good funding.
So this is an expensive--
And here's what Deutsch
and Josza have to say.
This is really Deutsche
at the beginning.
It's really quite spectacular.
Deutsch says actually, I
tell you what, give me a
million and a half, and I'll
do the computation give you
the answer.
At which point you think,
like I did previously,
the guy's clearly raving.
But, in fact, he's
going to make a profit,
And here's how he's
going to do it.
He's going to build, not
a classical computer,
but a quantum computer
using quantum interference
and entanglement to
do this calculation.
One evaluation.
And here's how
it's going to work.
And the first thing we have
to do is a preview, or set up,
in order to do this calculation,
you need two things.
First off, you need Matt to be
able to evaluate his function
in a way that respects
quantum mechanics.
So, in particular,
Matt had better
be able to do his experiment,
if I give him an superpositon.
So we better be able to
effect the calculation
in a quantum mechanical way.
The same way that we
implemented a NOT quantum
mechanically, or the
controlled-NOT quantum
Hadamard, with some set
of magnetic fields.
He must be able to implement
it quantum mechanically.
Otherwise, it's not an
interesting function.
And let me just point out that
any function you can think of
can be implemented
quantum mechanically,
because you are
quantum mechanics.
OK?
You're just not an
elegant implementation--
and no offense-- of the
quantum mechanical computation.
So the set up is that Matt
needs to be able to give me--
Matt provides-- a
unitary transformation,
a unitary operation, use of
f that takes two qubits, x
and y to x and f of x plus y.
Where what this means, f of x
plus y, is addition mod two.
So what this says is,
if y is 0, then this
gives me f of x plus 0.
If f of x is 0, that's 0
plus 0, so that gives me 0.
If f of x is 1, is this
gives me 1 plus 0, that's 1.
On the other hand, if y is 1,
then this gives me-- if f of x
is 0, it gives me 1
plus 1, which is 0.
And if f of x is 0, it's going
to be 0 plus 1, which is 1.
Everyone cool with that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
--question, but like actually,
how do you know that the matrix
actually [INAUDIBLE] I mean,
how can we know [INAUDIBLE]
if matrices actually prove that
quantum mechanics [INAUDIBLE]
What if the matrix is is
just an approximation--
PROFESSOR: You mean what if
quantum mechanics is only
an approximate description--?
Of the--
AUDIENCE: No I'm
sorry. [INAUDIBLE]
To what if quantum mechanics--
the inelegant reprensentation
of [INAUDIBLE] implementation
of quantum mechanics
PROFESSOR: Is inescapable--?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] is just
an approximation of the problem,
or is a really, really
good approximation--
PROFESSOR: This is an
interesting question.
So it's tempting
to think that this
is a philosophical
question, but it turns out
not to be in a way that will be
made sharp in about 10 minutes
with Bell's Inequality.
But a complete answer
to that question
remains open, and,
probably, always will.
But let me rephrase the
question slightly, and tell me
if this an accurate statement.
Look, at the end of the
day, what we're doing
is we're going to
develop a model where
quantum mechanical calculation
does something in particular.
And that may or may not be
a good model the real world.
And in particular,
whatever the actual thing,
the actual system, that
we're studying does,
may or may not be
well described by
that quantum mechanical model.
So can we check
whether or not it is?
Is that more or
less the question?
Yeah, and so the problem
is all we can ever do
is say that our model
is a good or bad model.
On the other hand, we
can do the following.
And this is the
really neat thing.
You might say, look,
underlying quantum mechanics
is going to be something
more fundamental
that's going to lead to
slightly different results
in exactly the
sort of situations
where we're going to
care about quantum
computation of large
numbers and bits.
And if you tell me just a little
tiny bit about what properties
that underlying
description will have,
that becomes an
empirical question.
So, for example,
if you say, look,
I suspect that underlying
the quantum mechanical
probabilities is some classical
probability distribution
over a hidden variable that
you have not actually measured.
And what we're
going to find out is
that we can rule that
out experimentally.
Just that extra
little assumption
that there's an underlying
hidden variable--
a secret probability
distribution on some variable
we just haven't
observed yet-- that
is enough information about the
system to rule out that model,
amazingly.
So I think we'll never have
a full answer your question.
But all we can do is work and
see how well our models fits.
And so far, nothing's
ever disagreed
with the quantum
mechanical description.
Let me hold off on
questions just now.
But it's a good and
interesting question
that's a hard one
deal with, by which I
mean it's an open question.
So Matt provides
for us an operator
that allows us to
calculate f of x.
Now you might have
said, well look,
why not just take x, and why not
have Matt build a machine that
takes x and gives you f of x.
Could you have done that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, it's
not exactly no cloning.
But let me leave this to you
as a fun thing to think about.
Why do we need this
carrier bit, as well?
OK.
So there's our set up.
Matt provides this
function for us, U.
And here's the algorithm.
So the algorithm.
And it's a series of steps,
one by one we do them.
We perform these operations
are on our qubit.
So here's what Deutsch says.
Deutsch says start input, a
state psi, is equal to 0, 1.
First qubit is 0,
in the state 0.
The second qubit is in
the state 1, for sure.
We implement that
with our boxes,
or however we want
to implement it.
So we find ourselves in a
definite state, you know,
hard-soft.
So we take a hard box,
and we take a soft box,
and we pull out the hard
one and the soft one.
One, Hadamard each.
Hadamard on both bits.
Both qubits.
OK.
So what does this take us to?
It takes us to psi
is equal to-- well,
the 0 goes to 1 over
root 2, times 0 plus 1.
Did I erase Hadamard?
No, good.
There's Hadamard.
So it does this-- does this.
So it takes the first
one to 0 plus 1,
and it takes the second one
to 1 over root 2, 0 minus 1.
Cool?
So at this point, this
isn't very interesting.
What we've done is we take
it from one superposition
to a different superposition.
And doesn't seem to have
anything to do with f.
In fact, we haven't measured f.
Two.
Apply f.
So we apply our
operation U sub f.
And well, this is a sort
of an entertaining one.
If we take this 1
of root 2-- so I'm
going to rewrite this in
a slightly simpler form--
this is 1/2, 0, times--
0 times 0 minus 1.
That's 1.
Plus 1 times 0 minus 1.
And the reason I'm doing that
is we're going to apply Uf.
And Uf, our function
f, uses that first bit
as a control bit for the second.
So here's the control
bit for the second.
So we apply Uf, and
this gives us 1/2.
I'm going to actually do
this on the next board,
because it's going
to be gigantic.
So this gives us 1/2.
0-- so that first one, this is
going to take this and give it
0 plus f of 0,
and 1 plus f of 0.
So times f of 0, plus 0.
Minus f of 0 plus 1.
Plus for the 1, this going to
be times f of 1, now, plus 0.
Minus f of 1, plus 1.
OK?
Now, here's a crucial step.
This is equal to, and
note the following,
look at this particular guy.
So for that particular
guy, suppose f of 0 is 0.
If f of 0, is 0, then this
is 0 plus 0, which is 0.
So f of 0 is equal to 0.
And this gives me 0, and this
gives me 0 plus 1, which is 1.
0 minus 1.
On the other hand, if
f of 0 is equal to 1,
then we get 1 plus
0, which is 1.
And here we get 1 plus
1, which is 0 minus 0,
which is equal to
minus 0 minus 1.
Yeah?
OK.
So I can write this as minus 1
to the f of 0 times 0 minus 1.
Everyone cool with that?
This is just a little
exercise in binary arithmetic.
So we can write this first term.
This is 1/2 minus 1 to the
f of 0, 0, times 0 minus 1.
So that's for the first one,
and exactly the same logic
is going to apply to the second.
But now f of 1,
instead of f of 0.
Plus minus 1 to the f of 1,
times 1, times 0, minus 1.
Now, I want to point
something out to you.
If f of 0 is equal to f of
1, than what's true of f of 0
plus f of 1?
Well, if they're
the same exactly,
then either it's 0 plus
0, in which case we get 0,
or it's 1 plus 1, in
which case we get 0.
So this is 0, if it's the
same, and 1, if it's not.
OK.
So we could either know them
both, or we can measure f of 0
plus f of 1.
So notice what happens here.
This is equal to
1/2, and now I'm
just going to pull out
a factor of f of 0,
minus 1 to the f of 0, times--
well, both of these terms
have a 0 minus 1
on the second bit,
so the second qubit is
in the state 0 minus 1.
Right, everyone cool with that?
So this is equal to, for
the first qubit, 0 plus 1,
times minus 1 to the f of 0,
that I pulled out to square it,
plus f of 1, times 0 minus 1.
And here's the quantity
we wanted to measure.
If this is 0, then they're even.
Then they're the same.
If it's 1, then
they're not the same.
So at this point we
just forget three,
forget about the second qubit.
Oh, lord.
Forget about the
second qubit, and so
forget about the
second qubit just
does this, just
focus on this guy.
And now, if f of 0 plus f of 1
is 0, so that they're the same,
this is 0, minus 1 to the
0, 0, so we get 0 plus 1.
So same, then our
state is 0 plus 1.
And if they're
different, then we
get the state 0 minus 1
Everyone agree with that?
But if they're the same we
get 0 plus 1, and different
we get 0 minus 1.
Still doesn't work
for us, because if we
measure, what's the
probability we get 0 here?
1/2.
And the probability
that we get 1 is 1/2.
Similar, if we measure here.
It was 0, 1/2.
1, 1/2
On the other hand these
states are familiar to us
because they're what
you get by Hadamarding.
So why don't we take these,
from these states to these--
by doing the inverse
of the Hadamard, which,
as it turns out,
is Hadamard itself.
So four.
Hadamard the first bit.
And the output is
the state, psi out,
is equal to 1/2, 1 plus,
minus 1 to the f of 0
plus f 1, 0 plus
1/2, 1 minus, minus 1
to the f of 0 plus f 1, 1.
And now, if f of 0 and f of
1 are the same, this is a 0.
We get 1 plus 1.
We get just 0, and this is 0,
because this is 1, this is 1.
They subtract we get 0.
They're same you get this
state 0, properly normalized.
If they're not the same,
you get this state 1,
properly normalized.
Now if we measure 0, we
know they're the same,
and if we measure 1, we
know they're different.
And so with absolute
certainty, now five.
Measure the first qubit.
And we get 0 implies the
same, and 1 implies different.
And we did all of this
with a single evaluation
of our function f, right here.
This is where we apply
our function evaluation.
We apply the function
evaluation once,
and we deterministically
get the result,
whether they're the
same or different.
So with one call to
Matt, to my Oracle,
with one call to Matt, which
cost me one million dollars,
we get the answer to whether
it's the same or different.
And that's a factor of
2 faster than the best
classical algorithm.
But that's not so satisfying.
This was supposed to be
exponentially better.
And so that's where Jozsa comes
in, and together with Deutsche,
Deutsche and Jozsa the
show the following.
That there's an exactly
analogous problem for n qubits.
Wow.
There's exactly analogous
from for n qubits,
the Deutsche-Jozsa problem.
And now, how many different
strings of integers
could you put in?
There are now 2 to
the n possible states.
And if you want to know whether
f is the same for all of them,
the worst case scenario
is you evaluate
f on the first possible
combination, 0, 0, 0, 0,
and you get some number.
You measure f on 0, 0, 0, 0,
1, and get the same number,
and just keep
doing that forever.
And you still don't know
if they're all the same,
until you get to
the very last one.
So, order 2 to the n is
the worst case scenario.
But technical scales are
of a order 2 to the n.
So classically, it
takes an enormous number
of observations.
But in the quantum
Deutsche-Jozsa algorithm--
and now in the n qubit
Deutsch-Jozsa problem-- one
quantum operation, and you
get a deterministic result.
And all of this, you evaluate
it once, and you know.
You've solved the problem.
So instead of 2 to
the n operations,
it takes a single one.
And now, for a large number
n of bits, for example,
for large integers-- dealing
with very large numbers--
this is dramatically,
exponentially more efficient
than the classical algorithm.
So at this point, people start
really seriously thinking
about quantum
computation, whether you
could get it to work.
And how much we
juice you can get out
of actually building
such a quantum computer.
And this has developed
into a whole theory
in the whole field of the
theory of computation.
The thing I want to emphasize
is that the crucial move
is observing that,
in quantum mechanics,
you can entangle
degrees of freedom.
The crucial move is observing
that you can entangle degrees
of freedom, quantum
mechanically.
And that's what gave us
all of the nice effects.
We have these
interference effects.
And these interference
effects lead
to the deterministic
outcome being correlated
with the result of
the computation.
The interference is crucial.
And this brings us
to the last point,
which is exactly what's so
troubling about entanglement.
And so here is
where EPR come in.
And Einstein, Podolsky, and
Rosen say the following.
They say, look, there are
two things that are deeply
upsetting about this
entanglement story.
Let me just give you a
precise experiment, they say.
They say, let me give you
precise experiment that
embodies all the
weirdness of this.
Suppose I take two
of these qubits.
And I put the qubits
in an entangled state,
up, up, plus down, down.
OK.
Let's normalize this
with a 1 upon root 2.
So there's our state.
And then we take the first
qubit, so there's our two bits,
we take the first qubit, we
send it somewhere faraway.
And someone named
Alice is sitting here
and is holding on to that bit.
And we take the
second bit far away.
And someone named Bob,
conventionally, is sitting here
and holds a second bit.
Now given this initial
of configuration,
what is the
probability that Alice
will measure the spin to be up?
Her spin to be up.
1/2, right?
And 1/2 down.
Similarly, Bob 1/2 up and down.
Once Alice has measured
the state to be up,
immediately she knows
something about Bob's spin.
Bob's state will be up,
because I chose this one.
I could have chosen the other,
which is the more popular
[INAUDIBLE].
So Bob's will also be up.
Now if you look at this list--
you do this over and over
and over again-- their list
just some random list of ups
and downs, ups and downs,
but they're exactly
correlated amongst each other.
So at this point, EPR
were really upset.
Because they say, look,
there are two possibilities.
Either there was an answer to
the question all the way along
of whether Alice's was
up and Bob's was up,
or Alice's was down
and Bob's was down.
Or there's some deep
non-locality in the universe,
such that a distant measurement,
causally disconnected,
can have an influence
on Bob's state,
such that they're correlated.
This may seem random, but
it's certainly not random,
because it's
correlated with Alice,
even though Alice is
wildly disconnected,
a distant observer.
Nothing could have traveled
across that distance
in the time it took
to do the measurement.
So they're sort
of three responses
you could take to this.
The first response is, look,
there isn't a problem here.
It's just saying that quantum
mechanics is insufficient.
There's secretly
a hidden variable,
a variable you
haven't observed yet,
a property of an electron
that determines whether it's
going to be up or down early on.
And the fact that it
looks probabilistic just
means that there's
some classical dynamics
for this hidden variable that
effectively is probabilistic,
like a particle
moving in a fluid.
Like dust pollen
grains in a fluid,
it just moves around randomly.
Bu it just looks random, and
it's not actually random.
That's because there's an
underlying classical mechanism
controlling the
probability distribution.
The second version is a
quantum mechanical version.
The second interpretation
is to say that, look,
this may look upsetting.
And I grant you that
it looks upsetting,
but I'm a quantum mechanic.
And quantum mechanics
works like a champ.
And I'm not about to throw
it out, and say that there's
some secret, hidden variables.
It just works.
So just give up on your naive
notions of locality, let it go,
and just do the quantum
mechanical calculation.
Practicing physicists look
at this, and just yawn.
If you're a practicing
physicist, you just forget it.
Like, obviously, it works, so
there's no more conversation
to be had.
So meanwhile, there's
a second version
of this, which is
slightly more disturbing.
Suppose Alice
measures up-- and this
is all on the z-direction--
but Alice measures up
in the z-direction.
She thus knows that
Bob's particle is up
in the z-direction.
But simultaneously,
Bob could measure spin
in the x-direction,
and determine
that his spin is up in
the x-direction as well.
At that point, EPR say, look,
we measured, empirically,
that the particle is both
up in the z-direction
and up in the x-direction.
It's just that we did that
measurement using entanglement.
But at the beginning
of the day, we
had that Sx and
Sz don't commute.
So you can't have a state with
definite Sx and definite Sz.
You cannot possibly.
It doesn't mean
anything to say so.
Einstein wants to say that this
is because quantum mechanics is
great, but incomplete.
The rest of us want to
say that, no it's not,
but that sounds like a
philosophical question.
And that's the
way it was treated
for a very long time, until
you come along to Bell.
And Bill made a
beautiful observation.
Bell said, look,
telling me that there's
an underlying probabilistic
classical description tells
me enough to make this
an empirical question.
Because it's saying
that the statistics,
the random statistics
for Bob and Alice,
are correlated by a
classical dynamics
rather than independent.
So here's Bell's version.
So remember at the
very beginning,
we talked about
Bell's experiment.
We said, consider three binary
properties, a, b, and c.
The number of some set
that are a and not b,
plus the number that
are b but not c,
is always greater than or
equal to the number that
are a but not c.
And the way we
proved this was just
by noting that, if these are
classical deterministic binary
properties, then a not
b means a not b and c,
or a not b and not c.
And ditto for each
of these other guys.
And we ended up
with an expression
which was, number that are
a-- using that logically to,
number that are a not b
and c plus the number that
are not a, b, and not c, is
greater than or equal to 0.
And that's clearly true.
You can't have a number
of elements be negative.
So this is trivially true,
quantum mechanically.
But now here's the
experiment I want to do.
I want to do actually
the EPR experiment.
And here's the
experiment I want to run.
Alice is going to
measure up or down at 0,
and Bob is going to measure
up or down at theta.
Alice is then going to
measure up and down at theta,
and Bob is going to measure
up and down at 2 theta.
And the third
experiment is going
to be Alice going to
measure up and down at 0,
and Bob is going to measure
up and down at 2 theta.
So a is up or down at--
up at 0, b is up at theta,
b is up at theta-- and, sorry,
this could be down at theta,
not b is down a theta. b
is going to be up at theta,
and c is going to
be down at 2 theta.
And a, again, up at 0 and
not c is down at 2 theta.
So we can rephrase this
as the probability that
given that we are up at 0,
what is the probability that we
are subsequently down at theta?
Plus the probability
that we are up at theta,
what is the probability
that we're up at theta
and subsequently
down at 2 theta?
And then the probability
that we are up at 0 and down
to theta, using an
EPR measurement, where
one is performed by Alice and
the other is performed by Bob.
Exactly as EPR wanted.
And we computed this
last time-- in fact
I just erased, because
I'm excited about this,
I guess-- I just erased the
wave function that we needed,
the state we needed.
And the state that we needed
was that if we are down
at the angle theta, then this is
equal to cosine of theta upon 2
down at 0, plus i sin
theta upon 2, up at 0.
And this is enough to
answer our question.
This is the quantum
mechanical prediction.
What's the probability
that given that we're down
at the angle theta,
we're up at the angle 0?
Well, if we're down
at theta, the probably
that we're up at
0-- the coefficient
is i sine theta upon
2, and the probability
is the norm squared of
that expansion coefficient.
So the probability is sine
squared of theta upon 2.
Similarly, the probability
that we're up at theta
and down the 2 theta, well,
by rotation by theta, this
gives me exactly the same thing.
So it's, again, going
to be sine squared,
sine squared theta upon 2.
The probability
that we're up at 0
and down at 2 theta, well, just
taking a factor of 2 for theta
everywhere.
And that gives me
sine squared of theta.
Now, I ask you, is left the left
hand side always greater than
or equal to the right hand side?
And this is easy to check.
Let's do this for
a very small theta.
For a very small theta,
sine squared theta.
So for small theta,
much less than 1,
sine theta squared is theta
upon 2 the angle squared,
which is equal to
theta squared upon 4.
And the next one
is the same thing,
plus theta upon 2 squared,
which is equal to theta squared
upon 4, theta squared upon
4, so theta squared upon two.
And the right hand side
is sine squared theta,
which is theta squared.
And is theta squared upon 2
greater than or equal to theta?
Certainly not.
So quantum mechanics
predicts that if we
do the EPR experiment, using
these observables repeatedly,
and built up statistics,
what we'll find
is an explicit violation
of the Bell Inequality.
And what that would represent
if it were actually true,
if we actually
observed it, would
be a conclusive empirical
proof that there
are no classical definite
configurations underlying
the probability of
quantum mechanical events.
It would say that it's
impossible to build
a classical theory with hidden
variables that are randomly
distributed such
that you reproduce
the predictions of
quantum mechanics.
We see already that it doesn't
agree with quantum mechanics.
The question is does it
agree with the real world?
So someone has to build
this experiment and check.
And this was done
by Alain Aspect.
And it violates
Bell's Inequality.
There is no
classical description
underlying quantum mechanics.
The universe around you is
inescapably probabilistic.
It evolves in a
deterministic fashion
through Schrodinger evolution.
But when we measure
things, we measure results
with probabilities.
And those probabilities cannot
be explained through some
underlying classical dynamics.
If there's something else
underlying quantum mechanics,
whatever else we know about
it, is it is not classical.
And this property of
probabilistic evolution,
or probabilistic measurement, is
an inescapable and empirically
verified property of
the reality around us.
And that's quantum mechanics.
Thanks guys.